i wish i had that because it's so lonely
at the top
and it's so lonely when you're high
achiever and it's so hard for you to
admit that you need help
um and just having someone to talk to
um that has been there and walk the walk
not just talk the talk is a big
[Music]
difference
ilana welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you
thank you it's amazing to be here i've
been watching your shows every time and
i just love it so that warms my heart
thank you very very much it's an honor
and a pleasure to have you here as a
guest
an entrepreneur at heart an entrepreneur
with
with adventures with an acquired venture
behind you already but but with a lot of
different
really interesting transitions a lot and
along your career
and and i'm particularly excited to talk
about your journey the insights you've
gained from these you know twists and
turns
the ups and downs and leading up to
golan ventures and
career leap which obviously is probably
one of the most
important conversations to be held in
the midst of a pandemic
so elana take it away who are you and
and how do you even get started into
this world so
engineer tech you know i've been in tech
for a while and kind of
moved up the chain from big companies
like intel to smaller companies and
startups
uh product sales kind of moved up the
chain all the way to vice president
all across the board and all across the
board leap to entrepreneurship
um with some ups and downs eventually
you know my company was acquired i moved
to the venture side and now i'm a public
speaker and forbes contributor
and um decided to just take all this
knowledge
and help others do the same because i
realized that
leaping in career is something that i
somehow know how to do
and i want to help others so i love it
you ended up getting to the realization
that you really love
helping people understand what what they
can do
and deal with that difficult moment you
know i have to say that
many entrepreneurs that i know most
entrepreneurs that i know there are tech
executives there
they've had businesses before they don't
turn to helping others
as a full-time job so what what really
motivated you to go and decide
now i'm going to spend most of my time
helping other people
realize what they need to do um it's
amazing question and that you know and i
honestly completed was this for a long
time like it's something i wanted to do
and
i was somewhat scared to do it um
and you know it was like somewhat i used
to be kind of this business woman and i
gonna be what like a
coach or i wasn't even sure i like
coaching and
um and i don't even see myself as a
coach i see myself more as a growth
strategist so
i wasn't really sure if this is the
right thing but i i found myself just
hoping a lot of people on the phone and
honestly you can't help a person
to leap in their career over coffee like
it just doesn't work first of all you
can't scale
and b it's not a one-time thing like
it's a journey and you have to be there
with them on the journey
and you know and i was looking for a
good way to do that
and eventually i just found you know
that i love doing this like i love see
people transform i love see people
change and
i wish i had that because it's so lonely
at the top
and it's so lonely when you're high
achiever and it's so hard for you to
admit that you need help
um and just having someone to talk to
um that has been there and walk the walk
not just talk the talk
is a big difference walk me through that
relationship that conversation that i
might have with you
as i need to make that leap now and and
and before that
dumb it down from a little bit what does
it mean for a person to want to make
that leap does it mean
that they are looking for a different
job they're not fulfilled they think
they can get hired to where they are
today
what what does that entail yeah
basically bingo like
it's everything is sad right i mean it's
usually the high achievers
right it's the people who are looking
forward and saying you know what there
must be more to life than what this
is and i could be doing more and i want
to leave more of a legacy and i want to
make more of an impact and i want to do
something that matters
and you know i'm probably at the you
know
last kind of quarter of my career and i
need to make it count
and at least at least two three quarters
ilana at least two three quarters
[Laughter]
so yes so i want to make it count and
you know it's
and i remember it for myself because i
used to wake up in the you know in the
middle of the night and i'm like it
can't be that this is it
like it can't be i'm over achiever and
yes i'm doing amazing things but
what's next like what's the next big
thing and you know just
so what i'm hearing what i'm hearing
from you is something that i that i'm
starting to pick up from from all the
different episodes and that is some of
that innate curiosity and passion that
you're
that that is burning inside you and
you're saying yes i'm doing all these
things i'm vice president of this and
i'm executive of this and i
founded this company but you're looking
to really understand how do i make that
tangible
impact on somebody and know that impact
so my question then
is is what is that impact so what is the
impact of helping people
make that make that leap in their
careers
how does that even translate to tangible
impact
right so i mean first of all just seeing
someone
that they're basically almost turned off
when
when you meet them yeah absolutely you
know they're unfulfilled they're
unmotivated
um they honestly take it usually home
you know they're not as happy per
se of a person they don't exercise as
much or not
as healthy as they want to be like
everything is kind of like a downhill
spiral and i was in that normal spiral
right so
so i feel it yeah oh why why were you in
the dominant spiral
story time oh my god so
yeah so i mean in a quick you know a few
seconds um
so we have time we have hours
i know you're like counting um so i
wanted to leave
from so i was already vice president i
started um
the u.s operation technical operation of
a become of an israeli startup here
um it grew to 15 million like it was an
amazing success and then i wanted kind
of that what's next right
so i wanted to lead to entrepreneurship
somebody i knew from the technion
wanted to do this together build it kind
of in the
off hours uh raise money eight hundred
thousand dollars
and right when i basically did a big
party
um for my previous job um to tell them
about the startup
um the same day he kicked me out so he
took the money
uh kicked me out of business and at some
point you know it's in within seconds
or a day i was left with nothing like no
job no salary no startup no investment
and
i felt like the earth just like fell
from under me right so it's that point
it's like
sorry for the language the holy
moment right it's like how you wake up
what do you do like what do i do do i
look for a job do i look for a
co-founder do i start a business like
what do you do um and you know and
you don't have to have these big moments
to really feel like
oh my god like i need more than this um
and i've had those small moments in my
life as well like you're as
an engineer you're many many times stuck
as a technical person
um and then you you know you move to
like product and then you're stuck as a
product so you keep on getting stuck
because you're good at it
right the question is how do you get
unstuck and it's a lot about reputation
and network these days
so that's really what plays a role and
the way people are
finding opportunities is different than
it used to be so
people will reinvent themselves every
year or two and it's absolutely right
you can learn right so we're talking
about a new reality you know it's not
just that we're living in kobe times but
i believe the trend
especially in the tech sector is that
every two years
people change positions for good and for
bad which means that
a lot more people have the potential to
reach that unstuck moment because
if all of my friends are advancing every
two years and it's my turn to advance
like holy i need to be advancing
just like my friends how do you get
unstuck walk me through some of the you
know some of the big pointers
uh for anybody that that may be stuck
that is present here with us
right right and i'll say a few things so
first of all
um again we will reinvent ourselves
every year to
and but and it's a skill but nobody
teaches you this skill
and what's more interesting is that the
roles that you're looking at especially
in the tech sectors
nobody really taught you marketing or
that kind of thing right
skills or that kind of management like
you don't learn that in school it's
really experiences and then you get into
that chicken and egg
like but you don't have the experience
so how can you do that right
so the interesting part here is how do
you
fast track to get those experiences so
that you can
claim it and you can have the confidence
and you can braille that reputation
so that your network will open these
opportunities your way
and that's how you leap so the the
unstuck is basically to figure out first
of all what you want to do
and which is crucial um and sometimes i
look at it as experiments
um just like startups experiment to
figure out their market
you know like where they want to go next
strategy that's the same thing you
experiment with your career you figure
out
one thing you try it for out you see if
it works you start building your
reputation network accordingly if you
don't like it change it
the beautiful thing is and you know i
say to the leapers in 2007 we all became
a media company and whether you like it
or not
if you nobody hears from you the
assumption is that you have nothing to
say
right so you know but we can leverage
this
um we can basically leverage it to tell
a new story about ourselves and its
power
wow how much of that is more is
emotional versus
in versus you know mental and
intellectual and
intangible and i'm just saying okay
here's the pros here's the cons and
here's what here is what ilana tells me
that i need to do so i should just go do
it so how does that
like what what is the mindset of a
person who is a leaper
in your mind um it's a great question
because i think it's exactly
all everything that you just said right
um it's not enough to just give
information these days i mean you have
information on youtube right you don't
need to
right so it's not about information it's
really about the transformation and it's
how about
how do you get to that transformation
how do you get that accountability how
do you get inspired by
people how do you learn about
opportunities you didn't even know about
right because when you're in corporate
and all you see is that senior director
role that you want
you didn't even know that you could
mentor in startup accelerators and join
boards and be advisor like you didn't
even know that these things exist
right so it's really about opening your
mind to what's possible but also
giving you the courage and the
inspiration to move on
and that accountability to keep pushing
because when
you you're scared you're gonna tend to
lean back to your comfort zone
um so it's really about everything it's
a lot of mindset
really it's it's fascinating it's all
but again it's all about fulfillment
and it's all about the pyramid of maslow
right that you that you want to reach
that that you want to reach that
hierarchy
and i guess one of the most difficult
parts of it is knowing
acknowledging that you're stuck right
i'm assuming that
it's very easy to get into a routine and
sort of being denial because it's first
of all it's comfortable to have
a position even if you're a little bit
stuck in it you're stuck
often in comfort especially in our
industry how
so there's a big part from when you
are stuck to when you go to alana golan
and she helps you
get unstuck i agree and and honestly i
do
what the big thing that i tell people is
that life is in phases
and in different phases different things
will be important for us
and sometimes it's really about finance
and comfort and balance and that's okay
you know as long as you're admitting
that this is what's important for you
right now and this part is okay
then it's okay right so when i was
you know in a big corporate and i knew
that i'm gonna have two children
and i'm gonna take two maternity leave
and i wanted to run an ironman and all
sorts of things
then you know it was okay for me to be
stuck because i wasn't stuck
i was doing the things that i love to do
right so
you know to some extent you need to
decide what's your must-haves
and once you define your must-haves you
need to say okay so now this is what's
important for me
and maybe it's reputation and maybe it's
recognition or maybe it's growth or
maybe it's more pay whatever it is right
now go chase it so the question that i
have to ask is
executive in tech two kids and an iron
man how does that work
well first of all i have to admit that
iron man was before the two kids
um but yes no i i i am
uh you know i need to be busy um
so i see that i can see that very
clearly
uh but that's life you know like you
know i
just want to make things happen i you
know i decide on the goal
and i go pursue it but i like to take
people with me
you know and that's the beautiful part
so now that i'm surrounded with
phenomenal leapers that are like
you know i see them growing i see them
fulfilled i'm seeing their eyes like
spark
like it's just something that i don't
think i've ever felt before
and you know it's first of all it's
fulfillment
it's it's you feel like you're impactful
and
beyond that it's you know it's the
financial freedom and the geography
freedom that i wanted for myself so that
i can keep on traveling the world and
still inspiring and making a lot of
money so it's great
i love it circling back because that is
a question that i'm fascinated by
i'm assuming that most people in the
world that that i mean i'm assuming that
the people that are already talking to
you that are stuck
they're the the top percentile that have
acknowledged it and are making that leap
but there is a whole there's a whole
level of people that are that are stuck
and they're just maybe they're not they
don't know it or they don't know what to
do about it
how how can you tell if a person is
exhibiting
the symptoms of of stuckness or or the
person who
who has the potential to make that leap
but just doesn't realize it yet
that's a great question i mean first of
all i have to say that i accept
roughly one out of five people that i
talked to so i really
picky yeah i am very very oh wow and the
reason is
um i want the people to have you know
enough of uh you know the goal needs to
be realistic
but high right and they need to be
committed they need to be driven they
need to be coachable resourceful
cetera right so yeah there's very
certain you know
type of people that i like working with
it's definitely more the high achievers
um in that top percentile um
you know people sometimes again they'll
feel stuck for a while
um but sometimes like i said it's
comfortable
right and we said that right but
sometimes it literally wakes you up in
the middle of the night or wakes you up
you know or
you know you see that you're anxious or
you're not yourself and you're not the
best version of yourself and at that
point
it's you know it took me many years to
ask for help
um now i have my own coaching and i pay
crazy amounts for it but it takes me
higher right
and you know i think it took me years to
understand that it's okay even though
i'm just like air force girl
right um that i probably shouldn't ask
for help and i should just figure it out
and
you know like figure you know kind of
prove that i can
um but actually when i ask for help it's
going to take me much faster and much
better
right so it took me many years to figure
it out and now i
you know i want to find the people that
will you know if i give them a hand they
will take it
and they will work hard and they will be
committed and they'll get
tremendous results it sounds like it
takes a lot of courage to do
both of these sides to play on both
roles right
yeah it's courage all the all along
right because
every time you leap you're going to be
out of your comfort zone so
the question is what kind of comfort
zone
and how big of a leap are you going to
go for
and leap is scary i mean you're going to
do by definition it's something you
haven't done before
by definition it's something bigger and
you need to decide that this is what you
want for yourself and for your family
and for your fulfillment so
yeah it's not right for everyone but
it's great
right one of the things that that i'm
still thinking from from a few sentences
ago is to say
you said the term coachable i never
thought of
you know the coaching as as it's a
two-sided market it's not just you know
that somebody's willing to pay and so
therefore
it's going to be a good fit but you need
somebody that's coachable somebody that
you will enjoy working with because
just as you're coaching them i'm sure
that a part of it is you're you're
you're talking about how you're getting
the fulfillment from them and you're
getting motivated by seeing them
progress and
and so you need people that will feed
you that motivation as well right
absolutely if i'm not 200 confident that
i can take them higher i don't want to
work with them
not because i'm a jackass just because
you know i want
i wanna see those results what i really
care about is the transformation i mean
i've had enough
like whether one person joins or not
that not gonna move the needle for me
but it will move that people to see
people that don't get the results so
um yeah so wonderful
just wonderful ilana thank you so much
for being so generous with your time it
was
lovely to have you here before we leave
i need to ask you for three words that
you would use to describe yourself
um i think i even said it um making
things happen
so things happen yeah i'm the type it
doesn't matter if it's a trip or an
adventure
or entrepreneurship or whatever i'm
gonna make something happen
and i'm gonna take people along with me
so
yeah amazing ilana thank you very much
yeah best of luck and thank you for
helping a lot of people along the way
it's really great